TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I am Timothy Jordan, and
this is an introduction
to Android Auto.
Commuters in the US spend
an average of one hour a day
in their car, and a person
checks their smartphone
an average of 125 times per day.
Now, cars get us
where we're going,
while our phones
keep us connected.
But using your phone while
driving can be distracting.
In fact, 25% of
accidents in the US
are caused by people
fumbling with their phones.
What if you could stay
connected using your phone,
but in a safer and
more convenient
way that's integrated
with your car?
And better yet,
what if developing
for this new platform
was easy and familiar?
Welcome to Android Auto,
bringing Android to the car.
It's the same
platform you already
use for phones, tablets,
televisions, watches, and more.
In fact, all these experiences
will often be in the same APK.
But now, your app
can also extend
to the car in a way
that's safer and more
efficient for the driver,
so they can stay connected,
but with their
hands on the wheel
and their eyes on the road.
Now, using Android Auto is easy.
Users go to the Google Play
Store and download apps
onto their phone that
support Android Auto.
They then connect
their phone to the car.
The phone goes into Car mode
and casts the Android Auto
experience to the car's screen.
Now, this means that although
all the apps and services are
actually running on
the phone, they're
displayed in the car's dash.
And you can interact with them
using the vehicle's controls,
such as a built-in
touchscreen and microphone.
You know what?
Let me show you how this works.
So I'm here in the
Android Auto building,
where the team's
getting some developer
tools ready for all of us.
Now, let's see if I can find
Daniel and borrow his car.
Hey, Daniel.
DANIEL: Hey, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How's it going?
DANIEL: Good times for
Android Auto developers.
Getting ready for the launch.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah,
it's going to be awesome.
Hey, the jet pack's working!
OK.
So I'm sitting in a
brand new Kia Soul.
And some people like this car
for the panoramic sunroof.
I like it for Android Auto.
I'm going to connect
my phone to the car.
And you'll see it
goes into Car mode.
I'll touch here, and Android
Auto starts up in the car.
Cool, huh?
Now, this is the
overview screen.
It's where you start, and
it contains contextual cards
based on the location,
the time of day, and more.
It's also the place where I
can find my notifications.
The activity bar is
here at the bottom,
and it contains a set
of common actions--
Navigation, Communication,
Audio, and car-related stuff.
You'll also notice
the microphone up here
in the corner.
I'll get back to
that in a moment.
But first, let's
play some music.
Let's tap here and
play this song.
[MUSIC THE MOWGLI'S, "SAN
FRANCISCO"]
You'll notice that even though
I'm in someone else's car,
everything is
running on my phone.
So it's all my stuff,
from my notifications
to my Play music account.
Anyhow, right now
we're in the App view.
Now, this is one of the most
interesting things for you
as a developer, because this
is where your app lives.
For user interface
consistency and to ensure
that all apps adhere to
the same safety guidelines,
the Android Auto framework
will display your app
in the standard UI template.
Now, this is also
what makes it so easy
to extend your app for Auto.
You don't need to worry about
the wide variety of display
configurations,
resolutions, different input
controls, or even that much
about driver distraction.
You just provide resources, such
as image assets, strings, color
palette, and supported
playback controls
to customize your
app without having
to define the entire
user interface yourself.
[BING]
Oh, hey, look, a text
message from Wayne.
I'll just tap it to play.
ANDROID: Hey, Timothy.
I hear you lifted
an Android Auto car.
Wanna ghost-ride it?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now, this is the
other really interesting thing
for you as a developer right
now-- message notifications.
You can take advantage of
these by using the Car extender
in the same way you use
the Wearable extender
for Android Wear.
Now, the last thing
I want to show you
is the voice interface,
which is where
I can reply to text
messages or search.
I just need to
tap the microphone
in the top right of the screen.
[BING]
Define "joy riding."
ANDROID: Joy riding--
the action or practice
of driving fast and dangerously
in a stolen car for enjoyment.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: [LAUGHS]
This thing is awesome.
All right.
Let's head back to the
studio and wrap this up.
OK.
Just a few last things.
Android Auto works by
projecting apps and services
running on the user's phone
onto the car's screen.
Now, this means you just need
to extend your existing Android
apps to work on the car.
And there's two great use
cases for that today--
audio and messaging.
Audio apps, such as music,
radio, and audio book players--
which are an awesome way to
stay entertained while you're
driving-- can now be
extended to the car.
APIs are available to expose
content, receive playback
control, and customize the UI.
Messaging applications,
which are a great way
to stay connected
while you're driving,
can now be extended
to the car, as well.
Now, APIs are available to
show notifications, play back
the message, and
reply with speech.
Android Auto brings the
Android platform to the car.
You can simply extend
your existing app
to work in the car,
allowing drivers
to be connected to
their virtual worlds
while staying focused
on the road ahead.
Please check out these
great developer resources
at this URL.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you on the road.
DANIEL: Where are my keys?
[DANCE MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Whoo hoo hoo hoo!
Yee-haw!